there's jenny osmond
loving the poster nice play by lonzo
ball's got numbers run brown ball back
to perusal tunnel let me get some butter
with that roll
give me that and they want to push the
pace they were able to do it here
unselfish basketball in caruso part of
an eight-point lead
so ball's got market in here
defense
tough defense by lonzo tipped by levine
and it's another shot clock violation
about this adam they don't even go down
the double team to help lonzo ball
rubio pumping brown trying to work his
way inside nice cut by barusso
ac
[Applause]
there he is right here he's just going
to go baseline goes up and under
nice scoop shot
he's going to be a fan favorite
people loved him in l.a absolutely
and i i think when you look at him
another time lowry in the defense by
derozan this time
[Applause]
nice lead pass for caruso back to
delusion
oh it's gonna be a lot of that this year
bulls fans
sexton into traffic turnover again
caruso
[Applause]
jared holland
watch this go get attacked watch the
afro
i'm hyped if they play at a high level
even a better level than what they saw
last year they're gonna get more easy
basketball first three on one green
ball love yes